this is a production of Cornell
University well good afternoon it's a
pleasure to be here every time I talk
about my mom and my dad I make sure that
my mom gets first place because in an ad
she said I was mentioned first and my
name was in bold so even though she's
passed today's seminar is going to be a
little bit different not a lot of data
but hopefully an idea of because I don't
think a lot of you then become Apple
breeders but a little bit of the
fascination that we find working in this
crap and working in any crop from a
horticultural or breeding perspective so
I'm very blessed and today I am NOT
going to be able to acknowledge everyone
that's been a part of this it really
does take a village and I've benefited
from my predecessors dr. Roger way and
Bob lamb when I came in 1985 I knew very
little about apples I knew enough to be
dangerous and they graciously
let me be the expert and not only that
they welcomed me into their home and I
hope that I can be as gracious when I
retire but despite rumors not happening
for a while okay I'm going to
acknowledge in the front in the back
because I know I'm going to forget
people so first and foremost have been
blessed to have an amazing research
support specialist in kevin maloney
and also David Terry before Kevin many
colleagues past and present in
horticulture entomology Plant Pathology
food science boys Thompson Thompson USDA
we have an amazing farm and field crew
we couldn't do our research without them
I have 73 plus acres 33 acres of
seedlings and we have to take care of
all of them amazing students including
some in the room and Summer Scholars and
we benefit greatly from Cornell
Cooperative Extension so today's talk as
I said I'd like to give a brief overview
and I want to convey the fun in in
research and breeding
I am blessed because I have
one of the best jobs that I can think of
you can discover and study and there's
always questions and there's more
questions than there are answers and
this arena especially you're able to
create something that's never been
created before so you are seeing fruit
for the first time that no one's tasted
no one's experienced and sometimes it's
amazing and other times it's not but
either way you learn a lot about it I
got my PhD in genetics because I worked
for a very renowned plant breeder Fred
Huff and he showed me miles of seedlings
and he said see this cross it didn't
work and I was like what a waste
I'm gonna go and I'm gonna become a
geneticist and that's not going to
happen to me huh you can know a lot
about genetics but there's always
something that gets in the way and then
the other fact is apples are incredibly
diverse I could not my apologies to
those in the room I could not work on
wheat or a commodity crop I need it to
be different and apples are far from
uniform and so I'm going to share some
of that diversity also apples bring out
the fanatics so one of our showcases
used to make an apple map of New York
State with apples now I'm gonna have a
showcase a week from now we're not
having that but it takes a lot of work
the other art work is in Sweden they
have a festival where they put apples on
nails and they make these huge beautiful
displays we also had a researcher that
came and visited the repository she was
fascinated with the apples and she said
I'd like to see other diversity and I
took her out to see some of our
architectural mutants and she fell in
love and she did a photo shoot now only
an LA photo expert can come and she said
can we bring snow machines if there's
not smell word upstate New York pretty
sure there's gonna be snow there wasn't
okay so I'm doing this for a colleague
that I hope is in Geneva
but apples are extremely popular so we
got a lot of requests and you know that
they are not enjoying the cabbage so we
are lucky to have something that gets
general interest and I just ticked off
half of the researchers but you'll get
used to me
so Apple doesn't have we get into a lot
of trouble because there's not a
consensus where there's a fight over the
progenitors so you know you're in
trouble when you can't even agree on a
name for cultivated Apple or it's also
incredibly diverse so we have triploids
tetraploid a bit mix we have 25 to 34
species and we haven't tapped the
surface of those we have an
incompatibility system and we have in
breeding depression so that means when I
want to incorporate a gene I have to
back cross it to something different and
then the plus is that it's clonally
propagated so when I find something I
can fix it now one thing that I learned
and would be helpful any of you students
if you can take a course on
communicating science to lay audiences
I'd strongly recommend it because one of
the best examples how many of you have
read the botany of desire okay that book
brought the attention to the germ plasm
collection because it was written in a
way that people resonated with people we
had people come on motorcycle across
country to see the Kazakh forests and I
was like don't you think you would have
called ahead to see if that's allowed
but it showed the power of writing
something from a lay perspective and
that is what were we're trying to do in
communication so I'm very fortunate that
the USDA repository has over 2,000 for
3,000 selections that I can use so the
government pays for them which is an
example of government funding that I
really like I don't have to pay for it
then and dr. agon yunjeong and dr.
thomas chow are involved and I also have
a graduate student that is in the
pathways program so he
a PhD with me and ganya Juan and then
will go on to work at the repository and
more about him later
when I came and started an Apple in 1994
this was the list of genes that we knew
you do a Google search now on Apple
jeans and you just blown away many of
which were reported by people like
LaLanne and Greg and others that you
know we're starting to understand this
so we've come an amazingly long way one
of the breakthroughs was the publishing
of the Apple genome from Golden
Delicious there's fifty four thousand
genes more than a chicken how's that for
you I'm gonna let you win the gibbering
Jeopardy category for apples and this
really helped us in terms of discovering
new genes and then recently dr. face lab
at BTW i followed and resequenced many
things to look at the history of apple
and how the evolution of fruit sized
happened so if you get a chance to read
this paper it strongly recommend it now
a lot of breeders especially when they
start out aren't going to do any
specific hybrids because they're going
to do a cross and they want to get a
variety they don't want to go back that
far and work with something that's very
small but when we started doing some
interspecific hybrids to actually to
work on been our Cheska's progeny we
found that a normal apple seedling just
grows like a stick when you use an inner
specific hybrid we got 21 laterals which
we don't see and we also get small
laterals also so the green house crew
were going by and they said talk about
hybrid vigor and so if you could see it
we had trees that were growing like
vines and this shows the great potential
that we have if we if we want to tap it
I'm a member of Rose breed which is
marker-assisted breeding it's a scri
similar to Bruce's Vitus Jen we were all
the the three major apple breeding
programs Minnesota Washington in New
York were all in the room and a grower
commented
if a bomb blew out there goes Apple
breeding in the US so you know unlike
areas like Japan where there's 21 Jeff
Apple breeders we we used to have an
Apple breeding program for every state
that probably wasn't necessary but now
fortunately we're all good friends and
we share germ plasm when we share the
data so that we can get more markers and
we have a great advisory panel with the
industry so first and foremost apples
need to satisfy consumers and so we know
with consumers the most important
attributes are Crispus crunch texture
flavor flavor being a little bit less
important juiciness sugar and acid
however they have to be consistent
because when you eat a bad apple you
remember it's worse than it was and when
you eat a good apple you remember it as
better than it was so you're kind of
stuck because you're saying hmm this
isn't as good as the last one or I think
I'm switching to bananas so we need to
make sure that we keep on having them be
consistent whether they're grown in
Washington Germany or here and we're
identifying markers to help us with that
consistency so as Don said were one of
the oldest programs one of the largest
programs we've named 66 varieties we
integrate breeding genetics and genomics
we are very much multidisciplinary as I
said I can't acknowledge half the people
that we benefited from and Cornell
Cooperative Extension is key to getting
our information out so we do controlled
hybridization and this is a great job
for graduate students right then taking
our pollen is a lovely thing to do while
you watch TV
so we take a lot of pollen out every
year we have to get to the blossoms
before bees do because they're going to
bring unwanted pollen and I learned and
anybody that's heard me lecture before I
got in trouble because my my new husband
at the time and I went out and I had
been working in the field all day and I
said said you look really tired I said
yeah I've been a mask
all day and he said please don't say
that so we make crosses and then this is
the beauty of it anybody has that has
kids you know the diversity that you see
but I get to have kids thousands of them
and if I don't like a particular mother
I can make her a father and I can I can
create promiscuity in the orchard and
just go wild with different combinations
and it's it's fun
so crosses and Families I hate the
Triscuit commercial where the lady says
she's not genetically modified so we
know were proponents of biotechnology
but we also get grief about our new
varieties about frankenfood so yes our
apples have been genetically modified
but they are not genetically modified
organisms so they don't have genes
outside of Apple so I give the example
of my children you want you picked your
parents and you want the offspring to be
different and you want the offspring to
be better and with children you
sometimes get that and sometimes you
don't we got double doses of
stubbornness of these two but the apple
progenies you're looking you don't want
them to be the same and because Apple is
so diverse that makes it easier so then
as I said you find something promising
and the sad part is sometimes you'll see
a seedling and that has two fruits and
Kevin and I will eat it oh my god those
are amazing and then you have to wait a
year and hope that it fruits again but
sometimes you'll find a very promising
seedling and then we clonally propagate
by budding so we take a bud from that
tree we can make hundreds of copies
we're fortunate at Geneva to have
somebody that works in the bottom part
of the plant the rootstock genera fazio
he gets as excited about the root system
as I do about the top and I really think
that we need to start looking at the
interaction between stop and sighin
because there's so much that could be
learned about that
so Cornell varieties that were best
known for Cortland is now an heirloom
being over a hundred years old McCowan's
getting close Empire and Jonagold and I
knew we were onto something when we were
asked to go to New York farm day in the
Senate and shall my student at the time
went with me and we're showing ample
samples and we were competing against
fresh oysters and wine and you know hors
d'oeuvres and were like oh this could be
a long night and a staffer came over and
she ate this Apple and she screamed get
out of here and she starts calling
staffers over to try these apples and
we're like okay well this is this is
looking promising and those are one of
them was Snapdragon little industry
overview if you don't know it we have
674 app growers we're second in the
nation McIntosh is still our number one
variety and then our growers were
finding they couldn't get access to a
lot of the club varieties like pink lady
or jazz or Pacific rose so we knew that
with Snapdragon and Ruby frost we had
two apples that were good enough to be
clubs but we needed an organization to
foster it we didn't want to give it to
one grower so we were looking for an
organization that didn't exist and this
is where I think my industry because all
these men and women have full-time jobs
producing apples packing apples studying
them thank you yes
so club means that it's it's managed so
a certain number of growers can join in
our case it was every grower in New York
had the opportunity we met we spend
money in marketing we set quality
standards and it is both patented and
trademarked and then anybody else has to
be sublicensed so there were clubs that
picked and choose so a brother might
have he might be a member of a club at
his neighboring farm brother was not so
we needed a new organization we needed
to move the varieties forward
higher and honorable took forever can
take 40 years before a variety becomes
popular at because the growers not going
to take the chance and growing a lot of
this variety unless he knows it has a
home and we needed dollars for marketing
a promotion so Hooker was the
Commissioner of a got the time and other
breeding programs have sold to in one
state they sold to a competitor state
particular fruit variety that didn't go
over well and surpass Booker said it's
gonna be a long walk to the governor's
office if you sound this to another
state so we told the growers we were
interested in doing it but they had to
offer to everybody we were going to be
equal partners and risks and rewards so
this is the core group that started it
and that was a nice day after about two
years of negotiations with IP so for
commercialization they committed to
plant nine hundred acres so that's gonna
give grocery stores enough volume that's
about 60 percent Snapdragon and 40
percent ruby for us they were going to
market and it was going to be in retail
stores stands in 2013 and in stores 2014
the reason we wanted stands is that
Honey Crisp was never marketed and it
certainly is a success but it was
because retail stands people got to try
it they got excited and so we wanted to
have that interface for consumers so New
York Snapdragon is a cross of Honey
Crisp buy a Apple that's very similar to
JA to gold so what I wanted is I like
Honey Crisp but I wanted more flavor
I wanted less of the disorders that it
had we tried this was the first tray in
the row and I told kevin maloney we
can't pick the first tree in the row
because our stomachs aren't you know
somewhere yeah so we went back and we
looked at it and it was like this is
pretty amazing and some growers signed
on to grow Snapdragon without ever
having tasted it but they saw pictures
of the productivity and they had faith
in the Geneva program
so Ruby frost was actually a study that
I'll show later that a graduate student
did I wanted to look at the genetics of
vitamin C increasing vitamin C and I
wanted to create reduced browning after
you cut them and so Ruby frost is a
hybrid of Braeburn by autumn crisp which
some of you might have tried at Cornell
orchards great reaction and consumer
tests and is high in vitamin C and low
in browning now I got to interact with
Deborah roseus class she had our growers
had the kids come up with ideas for
varieties now there was some if any of
you are still here I apologize there's
some really good ideas so they you were
so proud to be part of Cornell because
these kids some of them did it in
harmony they had you know merchandising
all set socks t-shirts one was Royal
Flush which may be a great card hand but
not a great Apple name but they did a
really nice job unfortunately we didn't
choose any of the names but it was a
great experience for all of them so
Chris Watkins and Yosef and Jackie maybe
I really benefited from Chris Watkins
and post-harvest now I told Chris he
said I'm not going to be here and I said
well you're not gonna hear the good
thing so that I say about you but he's
not here seriously he is great but I'm
once at a meeting said my apples are so
good I don't need a post-harvest
physiologist and Chris literally made me
eat my words so he's a Jackie and Franny
when she was here we established the
best picking dates we look at storage
disorders and we have growers sample
because they wouldn't believe that
certain harvests were better than other
and yosef knows how that goes so they
also learned that you don't stop at
Subway and get a 14-inch sub before
apple tasting because every
single one of these guys that Craig
photographed red and green so now they
know that you have to pace yourself but
it really having the industry involved
and what the best harvest date has been
really invaluable and I can't tell you
that
when you see your varieties in the
grocery store just nothing better than
that
because some breeders retire before they
see that now my husband was at the store
and I said what's the reaction you said
people are lining up for miles but we
still sell out and Helene Dillard when
she was here she went to the ethical
market and they only let her buy five
snapdragons and she said but I know the
breeder didn't help her so that's a
thing of beauty so this is going to
shift a little bit so any of you that
are working in horticultural commodities
understanding variation is key and it
can't be emphasized enough so you know
how to phenotype at the right stage we
had fights about this with rose breed
because they wanted to use a starch
iodine of eight the only thing a starch
iodine reading which shows maturity of
eight tells you is it's garbage and so
we had to pick it when a grower would
pick it understanding the right stage
minimizing variation so there can be a
variation to the fruit cluster the age
of the tree the rootstock the stage of
development the crop load and so by
computing garbage in garbage out but I
don't think you can't I can't emphasize
this point enough so like an apple if
you're doing a study on ethylene and you
have a king flower that's developed so
king dominant and laterals if you're
only picking the king fruit what's
happening when you're plucking that
apple off you're creating the wound and
you're creating ethylene
you're also having problems with you
know do you choose to look at the kid
where the laterals so understanding that
is important
sample size never enough never big
enough when you see somebody that looked
at five apples from a tree
that's not going to do it and apples as
I said are very variable the
developmental stage and what's happening
with ethylene so we have soutien got
here who's an expert on ethylene and we
need to make sure we understand what is
the stage that we're looking at is that
the best stage to be looking at now I
was switched to architecture a little
Bill Miller said don't let him down in
the seminar and even with columnar so
there's my mandatory columnar so
columnar is a dominant gene and weaping
as a dominant gene so what happens when
you cross them it is so you get they
fight it out so you get plumbing on the
top weeping on the bottom you got some
weeping you get everything in between
and it's just fun yeah I mean you just
get to go out there and and see this and
say you know Alan Alexa said that tree
is a tree that doesn't know what it
wants to be when it grows up now we know
that plant architecture branches should
go horizontal so we got a little carried
away not good for pruning but you can
see the variation again that's not
pruned
it's a wide branch angle it's awesome
mutation so unfortunately doesn't fruit
but you could have apples spokes of a
wheel and then just crazy so that is an
apple tree and I can bet money for
people that are like that's not an apple
tree and they even feel plastic the
flowers are like little Arabidopsis
flowers and it's just when I talk about
been we have different isomers of
compounds and some of these little leaf
things are just wild they have things
that shouldn't be no Kano's you is
looking at a lot of this material he got
a grant working with prosthetic and he's
going to be publishing on we painting
very soon and his group has been a
really valuable collaborators
then you just have stuff so that tree
its sisters or 20 feet high so what
makes it have all that growth condensed
and then this cross those are sister
seedlings the same age but one is dwarf
and one isn't so why and that's the
beauty of having graduate students so
Showa who we benefited greatly from
Peters willingness to let us use his
equipment expensive equipment and offer
mentoring was able to look at
gibberellin and vegetative tissues and
while we haven't commercialized this
these yet we have developed some lines
that are really good quality for
probably the whole market now when we do
a lot of mapping and genetic studies we
have skewed segregation and it's because
we have things like pale green label the
name is what it says they come out
yellow they die or dwarfs that most
people don't think they have they die
and so they don't know that those might
be linked with genes of interests so
been our Chesky it's always good to have
a graduate students that's as interested
in strange things as you are so he
started looking at columnar and he had a
side project until being lethal and he
found out that he'll gain lethal plants
were not able to to produce vitamin K
and that influences photosynthesis now
this is the beauty of Cornell I had
somebody contact me about arctic apple
and I googled them and dr. Parker what
Sir Ben says it's phylloquinone ok so I
googled dr. Parker and dr. Parker's an
expert on vial upon ohm like hey dude
could you run some tests and see if you
can detect this sure enough he did and
is an author on one of those papers so
what's cool about this is the pale green
lethal is this tiny little guy and when
you put vitamin K on it it starts to
grow it never quite rescues the
phenotype
but poor been sprayed vitamin K on these
plants and finally he said can I stop
this is like everyday but you can see
the black the blue line was where he
stopped application and sure enough you
have the restored phenotype but then it
starts becoming chlorotic and so it was
a great proof of concept between the
gene and the cause now bend the chairs
here and I had a picture of him with a
tomato plant and I don't hate veggies
but I wanted to have a picture of him
with apple trees well he brought in this
baby to see me this past weekend now I
have to ask you what has he told this
baby about his adviser but Ben is very
smart he has his defense Friday nothing
like bringing a baby and advisor so he's
coming the summer I'm not going to I'm
not going to steal his thunder about his
work and dihydride child homes but it's
really exciting he's given his exit
seminar Thursday and if you can attend
that would be wonderful
and I'll straighten it get out so sober
scholar it's what we are able to do is
we have a program at Geneva that for
eight weeks kids come there juniors or
seniors and for eight weeks they become
scientists now in eight weeks
granted we all have other stuff to do I
can't do a little search do a research
project and get a poster out of it
but every single one of these kids does
and they do amazing work so I've been
fortunate to have one every year
this is Kaitlin she's from Wisconsin
she's one of either 8 or 11 kids she
came to the station with a little
suitcase and I said you know don't you
have more stuff and she said well I'm
one of you know eight kids we had five
kids a three-year absent and triplets so
she's a triplet
she was really low maintenance so it's a
wonderful bright girl but loved being at
the station we
looked at ornamental crafts so Nina
knows I started in ornamentals and I
love them so this is my creative side
I'm not going to replace smart grant
with this she's frigid
with his Ostrom area but these are
columnar and different lobing and so she
was able to look at lo being and the
genetics of that in an eight week period
my last scholar before this year looked
at fruit set and cider apples so bad
were looking at and the beauty of apple
is she looked at fruit set and a malice
phosphor cross that we're looking at
because of tannin content for a hard
cider but she gets data that she can
publish because nobody's really looked
at fruit sadness
biron Rostock was my last sturdy and
Jeff was also a student in the the
Summer Scholars Program and he was able
to do phenotyping of a progeny that Ben
had done GBS for and was able to
discover a new QTL for the columnar
locust in that eight week project so
it's it's pretty amazing okay so I'm
going to wrap it up quickly red skin
color red is dominant to yellow but what
they don't tell you is what does that
mean so we have a red apple we can have
a green apple we developed a marker for
red and yellow but it didn't work for
green I have been trying to breed a
green apple and I have created the most
sickling Lee shade of greens that you
can ever imagine they they don't come
out pretty so we have learned that it's
due to a mid transcription factor we're
doing transgenic studies not us but
others on overexpression but the color
pattern whether it's striped or our
blushed matters now this is just the
kind of the Wow so these red apples
which I'm sorry I don't know your name
katie loves our sour they're going to
market them and I think I predict that
people are going to buy them once and
say well I was in the school and then
by the begun but I said that about
rocket apples and they got bought out
for 8 million so I better keep my day
job but what I'm showing you is the
Caitlin went out and she looked at the
progenation she said all the leaves are
green and I said that can't be they have
a dominant gene for red well look at the
laterals so I don't I can't explain this
the leaves came out green and then the
laterals produced red after that so
maybe a phase change so this is just a
bit of the diversity where we're looking
at beautiful double flowers scab
resistant different forms and shapes
emphasizing disease resistance we look
at resistance to scab and blessed to
have her bald Winkle a vase Khan care
Cox
a number of people that collaborate in
plant pathology and I'm gonna miss a few
we look at scab resistance powdery
mildew black rot climate change is real
we have southern diseases and you need
to know what your material is because we
love this novel stuff but another
breeder said well if you want if you
want my crazy stuff - I usually throw it
out but I think that we're going to
we're going to get answers by having
some of that crazy stuff so this I love
because this is one fruit in a
population of an ugly high-quality apple
i mean ugly by a speckled apple that's
good quality and you can see that i
think the yellow is an out cross but you
can see that you get varying degrees of
red and color you get ugly again and
then you get pretty amazing lenticels
and the quality of these things is
amazing so every single Apple is good
that does not usually happen Bruce knows
that there's a fruit size five genes for
fruit size I hit the jackpot on this I
can't win the lottery but I can line up
those genes for fruit size where we show
that he's going to pull an apple
so we're gonna laugh all the way to the
bank I don't think so
reduced vitamin C is important for Apple
dippers this was andreas research that
shows some of our advanced selections
are amazingly high in vitamin C compared
to the standard varieties we do
transgenic research when I say we I mean
lalang a vase
Kanaan so silencing is teaching us about
ethylene and Other Stories LaLanne has
reduced sorbitol lines and of course is
interested in arctic apples now I don't
I show this especially with Peter here I
am Pro biotechnology what it offers but
it's amazing what groups do to prey on
your heart because that's brilliant to
have a baby you know I'm a baby sucker
let's have a baby and Snow White and you
know it's not based on science but it
does resonate with a lot of people and
so arctic apples are being test marketed
now so we'll see what the public decides
we have a number of different hybrids
with potential for future
commercialization we're writing three
patents right now I apologize the
problem with having apples is I wanted
to bring some today but they're not
easily carried so I owe you one again
acknowledged in current and former
students my technicians Cornell
colleagues USDA everybody has been
amazingly generous we've been able to
garner funding from different sources
and I showed the shop Martin definitely
after fall to show that we really are
creating some very productive apples but
somebody asked me why I engineered them
not to have leaves so thank you for
attending and I'm glad to answer any
questions if anybody has them and I'm
going to reach out to my Geneva crew
because I feel bad that I'm not there so
Geneva do you have any questions I
learned from Kevin this fall that
Snapdragon does not drop below
on the fruit a pressure of 20 and
therefore you have to decide when to
pick it by the starch number and so is
that a beneficial character which
improves this post-harvest behavior and
if so are we going to see more
selections very similar yeah we have a
we have a lot of selections that are
performing very well from a storage and
shelf-life perspective
thanks Jay any other questions of Geneva
okay if it was turned on many years ago
we had a researcher from Geneva film
Forest Lawn yes
speak about the origins and in your
early years of breeding were you able to
learn from um feels a wonderful person
and at that time I was not so interested
in going back and quality so malice
adversity is the progenitor species but
it's yellow it falls off the tree it's
pretty acid and so I admit that I you
know kind of put it aside now we are
very much embracing the use of inertia
Pacific hybrids Phil is going to be with
her bill all dwink Alon a CBS News show
on the Cossack apples and their trip to
to the center of diversity so I probably
should have but I didn't Peter yeah so
that's the key is you need you want a
branch angle to be as close as 90
degrees as possible that's the strongest
branch homeowners tend to have very you
know they're not pruning it or training
it they'll be like this and then that's
weak and it'll just crack yes and also
not dropping the fruit that has its
disadvantages because if fruit don't
draw the when we thin them some
money stayin and that's a a veneer for
further diseases I got criticized that
my apples are too firm and I was like
that's not criticism you know I
understand that people with dentures
aren't going to like it but just use a
knife then you know type does the the
would stop and I'm sorry and I
apologized so the progeny because I
forgot to repeat the question so the
question is if the rootstock affects the
variety absolutely so there are
resistances and the root stocks it can
make them bear earlier it influences
branch angle which I thought was
brilliant
there's also influences on calcium and
magnesium so the work that were laying
them been and others are doing so the
rootstock holds a lot of potential and
that's why I really think being able to
study what gets transported and what
doesn't would be hugely helpful
okay so he was asking about how does a
club work what about when other people
outside of New York State want access so
one grower asked if he could buy a foot
of land in New York and become a New
York grower we do have the ability to
sublicense and I think in the future
cosmic crisp is going to come from
Washington with millions and millions of
boxes so I think we will sublicense to
other states but for international
marketing we are we are going to license
to other countries with the caveat that
they can't export into the u.s. so that
protects our our industry we had a
grower from a nursery mint from Belgium
and he said we went out to dinner and he
asked the waitress about Snapdragon and
she just looked at him like
what and he said I came all the way from
Belgium to test this variety and she
said this is where you get humbled sure
you did any other questions
tastes like very sweet
how do you deal with that your selection
okay so I so the question was how do you
deal with that some like 70% of the
population tends to like a sweet apple
where 30% tends to like the tart apple
how do we deal with that in our breeding
i i've been consumers if they're exposed
to something outside of their comfort
zone will embrace it
and so i think especially we're losing a
lot of the kid market and i think we
have some robust things that children
would like more than adults so i'm
selecting a wide range of things and I'm
not going for middle-of-the-road because
that's a dangerous precedent to say well
you've been a great audience thank you
very much this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu